- Bentornati a Capire l'Informazione
e il Calcolo Quantistico.
Mi chiamo John Watrous, e sono il direttore tecnico
dell'Education di IBM Quantum.
Questa è la seconda lezione della serie. Se non hai ancora
guardato la prima lezione, assicurati di farlo.
Costruiremo direttamente su ciò di cui abbiamo parlato
nella prima lezione, quindi è importante avere una
comprensione di quel materiale prima di iniziare questa lezione.
Tieni presente che la serie
include contenuti del libro di testo oltre ai video, e puoi trovare un link
al contenuto del libro di testo
nella descrizione del video. Questa è la lezione due della
unità uno della serie.
L'unità uno copre le basi
dell'informazione quantistica.
Nella lezione precedente, abbiamo parlato dell'informazione quantistica nel contesto dei sistemi singoli, ovvero che abbiamo un
sistema che memorizza informazioni
e descriviamo come
funziona in isolamento.
Abbiamo dedicato una buona quantità di
tempo all'informazione classica, principalmente per stabilire un punto di riferimento e per evidenziare le
somiglianze matematiche
tra informazione quantistica e classica.
Abbiamo anche visto come gli stati quantistici possono essere rappresentati da vettori, in particolare vettori con
elementi di numeri complessi e norma euclidea pari a uno,
e abbiamo discusso le misurazioni nella
base standard e le operazioni unitarie.
In questa lezione, espanderemo la nostra
visione a più sistemi, ognuno dei quali è in grado di
memorizzare informazioni quantistiche.
Non si tratta semplicemente di dire che ogni singolo sistema
funziona come abbiamo discusso l'ultima volta, c'è un senso in cui il tutto
è maggiore della somma delle parti, e questo vale anche per
l'informazione classica quando sono coinvolte le probabilità.
I sistemi multipli possono
interagire tra loro e possono essere correlati
tra loro ad esempio, e nel contesto quantistico, ciò include la possibilità
che i sistemi siano entangled, un termine che
potresti aver già sentito.
L'entanglement è un fenomeno molto
importante nell'informazione quantistica e avremo molto altro da dire al riguardo man mano che la serie continua.
C'è un principio semplice, tuttavia, che ci offre molta trazione per pensare e
comprendere l'informazione quantistica per sistemi multipli,
ed è che possiamo sempre
prendere due o più sistemi e metterli insieme o semplicemente
pensarli concettualmente insieme
e vederli come se formassero
un singolo sistema composto.
E quando pensiamo a un
sistema composto in questo modo, come se fosse un sistema singolo, riconosciamo che deve essere descritto in modo coerente
con tutto ciò che abbiamo imparato
nella lezione precedente sui sistemi singoli.
Vedremo come funziona
e come la descrizione dell'informazione quantistica
per sistemi multipli emerge in modo abbastanza naturale da come funziona per i sistemi singoli
sulla base di questo unico principio. Ecco una panoramica della lezione ed è identica alla panoramica della lezione precedente,
ma questa volta la nostra attenzione
sarà sui sistemi multipli anziché sui sistemi singoli.
Proprio come abbiamo fatto nella lezione precedente e per esattamente le stesse ragioni, inizieremo con
l'informazione classica.
Ancora una volta, vedremo
somiglianze molto strette tra il modo in cui l'informazione quantistica
e classica funzionano a livello matematico.
Di solito non ci concentreremo così
tanto sull'informazione classica né inizieremo ogni lezione della serie con l'informazione classica in questo modo.
Le lezioni successive tenderanno a essere concentrate molto più esclusivamente sull'informazione e il calcolo quantistico.
Ma qui all'inizio
questo è un approccio sensato e torna all'idea che pensare all'informazione classica
può servire come una preziosa fonte di orientamento per comprendere l'informazione quantistica.
Discuteremo anche
il concetto importante del prodotto tensoriale in
questa parte della lezione.
I prodotti tensoriali sono di fondamentale importanza nell'informazione quantistica, ma emergono anche nel
contesto classico.
Poi passeremo all'informazione quantistica e, proprio come nella lezione precedente, discuteremo gli stati quantistici,
le misurazioni nella base standard,
e le operazioni unitarie questa
volta per sistemi multipli.
Inizieremo parlando
degli stati classici dei sistemi multipli.
Ricorda dalla lezione precedente
che uno stato classico di un sistema è una
configurazione di quel sistema che può essere riconosciuta e
descritta senza ambiguità
senza alcuna incertezza o errore. E in termini matematici, quando ci riferiamo a un insieme di stati classici,
intendiamo semplicemente un insieme finito e non vuoto.
Inizieremo la nostra discussione
sui sistemi multipli supponendo di avere
solo due sistemi X e Y.
X ha un certo insieme di stati classici che chiameremo sigma proprio
come nella lezione precedente, e Y ha un insieme di stati classici
che chiameremo gamma. L'insieme sigma e gamma
potrebbero essere lo stesso insieme o potrebbero essere diversi,
ma diamo loro nomi diversi, non solo perché
potrebbero essere insiemi diversi, ma anche perché ci aiuterà
a mantenere le cose chiare se diamo loro nomi diversi.
Troveremo che è
abbastanza facile generalizzare l'intera discussione da due sistemi a qualsiasi numero di sistemi, ma
partendo da due sistemi,
possiamo concentrarci sulle idee fondamentali senza perderci nei dettagli.
WEBVTT
Ora immagina di
mettere X e Y fianco a fianco con X a sinistra e Y a destra, e di vedere questi due sistemi insieme
come se formassero un unico sistema composto.
Per dare un nome a questo nuovo sistema, possiamo scriverlo come una
coppia ordinata in questo modo, o possiamo semplicemente giustapporre
le due lettere in questo modo.
Entrambi sono comuni e
possiamo scegliere quello che vogliamo o quello che è più conveniente.
In ogni caso, lo leggeremo come XY.
Una domanda molto naturale
da porsi a questo punto è quali sono gli stati classici di questo nuovo sistema composto XY?
E la risposta a questa domanda è che l'insieme degli stati classici di XY è il prodotto cartesiano dei
due insiemi di stati classici,
sigma e gamma, che puoi
vedere definiti proprio qui.
In un dato momento, X ha un certo stato classico
che è un elemento di sigma, e Y ha un certo stato classico
che è un elemento di gamma,
e semplicemente pensiamo
a questi due stati insieme come se formassero un unico stato, e questa è esattamente la nozione
che il prodotto cartesiano cattura. Abbiamo due elementi,
uno da ciascuno dei nostri insiemi, e vogliamo pensare
a questi due elementi insieme
come se formassero un singolo
elemento di un singolo insieme.
Per essere chiari, c'è un'assunzione qui, ovvero che sappiamo
quale dei nostri sistemi è X e quale è Y,
e non c'è confusione tra loro. Non è importante che X sia fisicamente sul lato sinistro
e Y a destra,
ma piuttosto che i due
sistemi siano distinguibili e che abbiamo deciso
di ordinarli in questo modo solo per poter tenere
traccia di quale è quale.
Ecco un esempio molto semplice in cui sigma è l'alfabeto binario e gamma è l'insieme
contenente i quattro semi delle carte.
Se X memorizza un valore binario e Y memorizza uno dei quattro semi delle carte, allora ci sono otto
possibili stati classici
della coppia XY, che puoi
vedere elencati proprio qui.
Per più di due sistemi, questo si generalizza in modo diretto.
In particolare, se X1 fino a Xn sono sistemi con
insiemi di stati classici sigma uno fino a sigma n rispettivamente.
Poi, se immaginiamo di raggruppare
gli n sistemi insieme e di vederli come un unico sistema, l'insieme degli stati classici è
dato dal prodotto cartesiano
degli n insiemi di stati classici
sigma uno fino a sigma n.
Come puoi vedere qui sullo schermo. Il prodotto cartesiano
può essere definito in questo modo per qualsiasi numero di insiemi.
Per esempio, se abbiamo tre sistemi e condividono tutti l'alfabeto binario come insieme di stati classici, quindi in altre parole abbiamo tre bit,
allora ci sono otto
possibili stati classici dei tre bit visti
insieme come un unico sistema e puoi vederli elencati proprio qui.
Ogni sistema individualmente può
essere nello stato zero o uno, e spazioamo su tutte le
possibili combinazioni.
Una n-upla di stati classici può essere scritta alternativamente come una stringa in cui eliminiamo le
parentesi e le virgole come vedi qui.
E questo è particolarmente sensato quando pensiamo agli
stati classici come simboli, come nel comunissimo esempio
dell'alfabeto binario
a cui torniamo continuamente. A volte è molto conveniente farlo e tende a rendere
le nostre espressioni più semplici
e meno disordinate. La nozione di stringa è di fatto formalizzata
in termini matematici attraverso i prodotti cartesiani,
quindi questa è davvero
solo una notazione alternativa e non qualcosa di concettualmente diverso.
Come esempio, diciamo che abbiamo
10 bit X1 fino a X10.
Ciò significa che l'insieme degli stati classici dei 10 bit insieme,
che potresti naturalmente pensare come un registro a 10 bit
in un computer ad esempio,
è il prodotto cartesiano dieci volte
dell'alfabeto binario con se stesso.
E se scriviamo quegli stati come stringhe, sembrano come vedi
qui, ce ne sono 1.024,
quindi ovviamente non sono tutti elencati qui. Questi tre puntini qui
sono intesi a indicare che c'è uno schema che puoi dedurre
e speriamo che tu abbia capito l'idea. Ora c'è una convenzione
che seguiremo per ordinare gli elementi
degli insiemi prodotto cartesiano,
ed è importante
chiarirlo per il bene della rappresentazione sia degli stati probabilistici che degli stati quantistici come vettori.
La convenzione è che
ordiniamo gli elementi degli insiemi prodotto cartesiano
lessicograficamente, il che significa sostanzialmente l'ordinamento del dizionario.
Per essere più precisi, partiamo dall'assunzione che ciascuno dei singoli insiemi di cui stiamo prendendo il prodotto cartesiano abbia già il suo ordinamento
e pensiamo a una
data n-upla o a una stringa come se fosse una parola e le ordiniamo alfabeticamente.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che le posizioni all'interno
di una n-upla o di una stringa diminuiscono in importanza
da sinistra a destra,
proprio come quando scriviamo numeri usando le cifre da zero a nove.
Ecco un esempio
pensato per chiarire questo.
Se prendiamo il prodotto cartesiano tra l'insieme contenente
uno, due e tre e l'alfabeto binario, otteniamo un insieme contenente sei elementi
e qui sono elencati nell'
ordine che viene descritto.
Tutti gli elementi con un
uno nella prima posizione vengono prima di tutti gli elementi con un due nella prima posizione e vengono prima di tutti gli elementi
WEBVTT
con un tre nella prima posizione. E quando due elementi
concordano nella prima posizione, ricadiamo sull'ordinamento
nella seconda posizione.
Questo è dunque l'ordinamento che
usiamo per i prodotti cartesiani.
Nota che quando usiamo questa convenzione e scriviamo le n-uple come stringhe, osserviamo alcuni schemi molto familiari.
Per esempio, il prodotto cartesiano dell'
alfabeto binario con se stesso è ordinato come vedi qui,
e puoi pensare a queste stringhe come se fossero ordinate numericamente se prendi queste stringhe
come codifiche binarie di interi non negativi e questo si generalizza
a qualsiasi lunghezza di stringa. Passando agli stati probabilistici, sappiamo già dalla lezione precedente
che uno stato probabilistico associa una probabilità a ciascuno
stato classico di un dato sistema.
Se abbiamo un sistema composto in cui abbiamo preso due o più sistemi e li stiamo vedendo collettivamente come se formassero un unico
sistema come abbiamo appena discusso,
allora uno stato probabilistico
di questo sistema composto deve assegnare probabilità agli elementi del prodotto cartesiano
dei singoli sistemi,
degli insiemi di stati classici. Questo perché quello è
l'insieme degli stati classici del sistema composto.
Per esempio, supponendo
che X e Y siano bit, abbiamo questo esempio di uno
stato probabilistico di XY.
La probabilità che entrambi
i bit siano zero è un mezzo e la probabilità che entrambi
i bit siano uno è un mezzo, e quindi i due bit non sono mai in disaccordo.
È uno stato probabilistico valido di XY, e possiamo alternativamente
scriverlo come un vettore
come vedi qui e qui puoi vedere che
stiamo seguendo la convenzione che ho descritto poco fa per ordinare questi stati classici.
Questo è un esempio di
uno stato probabilistico in cui X e Y sono correlati, e questo è il senso in cui il tutto
è maggiore della somma delle parti. Come ho suggerito prima, non è semplicemente che abbiamo uno stato probabilistico
di X e uno stato probabilistico di Y e li mettiamo insieme, ma piuttosto prima mettiamo
i sistemi insieme
e poi pensiamo agli
stati probabilistici del sistema composto.
Per essere più precisi riguardo alle
correlazioni tra sistemi. Iniziamo definendo la
nozione di indipendenza, che è essenzialmente
l'assenza di correlazione.
Qui tra l'altro, il termine indipendenza si riferisce
all'indipendenza statistica in contrapposizione all'indipendenza lineare
dei vettori ad esempio.
È una nozione fondamentale in
probabilità e statistica.
Se abbiamo due sistemi X e Y e abbiamo in mente un certo stato probabilistico
di XY, allora diciamo che X e Y sono indipendenti.
Se la formula che
vedi qui è vera per ogni scelta di stati classici
a e b di X e Y.
Un modo per interpretare questa
condizione di indipendenza è che dice che la probabilità per X di essere in un qualsiasi stato classico
e la probabilità per Y di essere in un altro stato classico non hanno assolutamente nulla
a che fare l'una con l'altra.
Quindi, sapere in quale stato
si trova uno dei sistemi non influenza le
probabilità associate agli stati dell'altro sistema.
Se immagini di scegliere casualmente
un certo stato classico di X secondo una certa procedura e poi di scegliere casualmente
un certo stato classico di Y
secondo qualche altra procedura che non è in alcun modo
collegata a quella per X, come ad esempio se una persona lancia una moneta
e un'altra persona in una
stanza diversa lancia un dado, allora questa è la formula
che useresti per ottenere le probabilità
per le diverse combinazioni
di stati che appaiono. Il punto della definizione è che l'indipendenza è
quando la formula è valida.
Quando pensiamo agli stati probabilistici in termini di vettori di probabilità, c'è una formulazione semplice
di questa condizione
specificamente se abbiamo uno
stato probabilistico di XY, che possiamo esprimere come
un vettore nella notazione diretta
come vedi qui. Allora dire che X e Y sono indipendenti è equivalente all'esistenza
di due vettori di probabilità,
ket Phi e ket Psi che tra l'altro possiamo
semplicemente leggere come Phi e Psi per brevità, rappresentando
stati probabilistici di X e Y separatamente che soddisfano questa uguaglianza
che vedi qui.
Per tutte le scelte di a e b, è essenzialmente una
riformulazione della definizione in termini di vettori.
Per esempio, ecco uno stato probabilistico
di una coppia di bit XY per cui X e Y sono indipendenti.
La condizione richiesta
per l'indipendenza è vera per i vettori
che vedi qui.
Cioè la probabilità
per ogni possibile configurazione dei due bit è data dal prodotto delle corrispondenti probabilità
per i bit individuali.
Per esempio, la probabilità che entrambi
i bit assumano il valore zero è pari a un sesto, che è uguale a un
quarto per due terzi,
e allo stesso modo per le
altre tre possibilità che possono essere verificate una alla volta.
Per lo stato probabilistico che abbiamo visto in precedenza d'altra parte, in cui abbiamo
due bit che concordano sempre e assumono i valori zero e
uno con probabilità un mezzo
non abbiamo indipendenza ed è per questo che diciamo che
i bit sono correlati.
La correlazione significa semplicemente
una mancanza di indipendenza.
Un modo semplice per argomentare che i
due bit non sono indipendenti è supporre che lo siano e derivare una contraddizione
specificamente se i due
bit fossero indipendenti, dovrebbero esistere
i numeri q0, q1, r0 e r1
WEBVTT
che rappresentano le probabilità
per i due bit individuali in modo che queste equazioni
qui siano soddisfatte.
Queste sono le probabilità
che vengono dal nostro vettore e queste sono le
equazioni che devono essere vere per la condizione di indipendenza,
ma se guardiamo questa
seconda uguaglianza qui, vediamo che richiede che
q0 per r1 sia uguale a zero,
ma l'unico modo in cui il
prodotto di due numeri reali può essere uguale a zero è se almeno uno di quei
numeri stesso è uguale a zero.
A volte questo viene chiamato
la proprietà del prodotto zero dei numeri reali.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che il prodotto di due numeri reali diversi da zero
è sempre diverso da zero.
Quindi questa uguaglianza qui
implica che o q0 è uguale a zero o r1 è uguale a zero,
ma dalla prima e dall'ultima uguaglianza vediamo che nessuna delle
due alternative può essere vera.
Se q0 è uguale a zero, allora questo prodotto deve essere uguale a zero, ma non è uguale a zero
e se r1 è uguale a zero,
allora questo prodotto deve essere uguale a zero, ma non è vero neanche questo.
Quindi abbiamo una contraddizione
e concludiamo che X e Y non sono indipendenti quindi sono correlati.
La nozione di indipendenza
che abbiamo appena discusso e in particolare la sua formulazione in termini di vettori di probabilità
è strettamente connessa
a un'operazione che può
essere eseguita sui vettori nota come prodotto tensoriale.
I prodotti tensoriali possono essere
definiti non solo per i vettori ma anche per le matrici
e in realtà la nozione di prodotto tensoriale può essere definita
per molti altri tipi di
oggetti matematici.
Possono essere descritti
in modo abbastanza astratto che è sia importante che
utile nella matematica pura, ma possiamo anche definire
prodotti tensoriali per vettori
in un modo molto semplice e concreto, e questa è la strada che
seguiremo in questa lezione.
Se abbiamo due vettori colonna Phi e Psi scritti nelle forme che vedi qui dove sigma e gamma sono qualsiasi
scelta di insiemi di stati classici
che vogliamo o indici se preferisci, allora il prodotto tensoriale di questi vettori è il vettore che vedi proprio qui.
Spazioiamo su tutti gli elementi
del prodotto cartesiano dei due insiemi, sigma e gamma, e l'elemento di questo
vettore che corrisponde
a ciascuna coppia ab, che è
scritta come una stringa qui, è uguale al prodotto degli elementi
corrispondenti
di questi due vettori. In altre parole, l'elemento ab di Phi tensoriale Psi è il prodotto dell'elemento a
di Phi e dell'elemento b di Psi,
e questo è il significato di
ciò che è scritto qui.
In sostanza, questa è la stessa operazione che abbiamo visto pochi istanti fa quando abbiamo discusso l'indipendenza
e ora stiamo semplicemente dandole un nome.
Ecco esattamente lo stesso esempio
che abbiamo visto poco fa scritto più esplicitamente in
termini di prodotto tensoriale.
Ancora una volta, abbiamo che un sesto è uguale a un quarto per un terzo, un dodicesimo è uguale a un quarto
per un terzo e così via.
Qui tra l'altro ci sono
un paio di modi alternativi per scrivere il prodotto
tensoriale di due vettori.
Quando usiamo la notazione diretta e scriviamo due ket
uno accanto all'altro in questo modo, significa il prodotto tensoriale.
Quindi puoi pensare al prodotto tensoriale come una sorta di modo predefinito per moltiplicare due vettori colonna insieme.
Non avrebbe senso
pensare a un prodotto di vettori colonna come questo in termini di moltiplicazione di matrici perché le dimensioni non funzionano,
quindi non c'è davvero alcun rischio
di ambiguità qui.
Possiamo anche scrivere il
prodotto tensoriale in questo modo all'interno di un ket e significa
esattamente la stessa cosa.
È il prodotto tensoriale
dei due vettori.
Il primo è molto comune e in realtà è forse più comune scrivere un prodotto tensoriale in questo modo senza il simbolo del prodotto tensoriale
che includerlo. Il secondo è
sicuramente molto meno comune, ma a volte è abbastanza utile principalmente
come modo per eliminare la necessità
di parentesi aggiuntive in certe situazioni.
Possiamo anche esprimere
prodotti tensoriali esplicitamente in termini di colonne effettive di
numeri come vedi qui,
se prendiamo il prodotto tensoriale di questi due vettori colonna qui, allora questo è il vettore che otteniamo
e puoi vedere che gli elementi qui sono prodotti degli elementi
provenienti da questi due vettori.
L'ordinamento degli elementi
del prodotto tensoriale è coerente con la
definizione di poco fa a condizione che seguiamo la convenzione
che ho descritto in precedenza per ordinare gli elementi
degli insiemi prodotto cartesiano.
Seguire quella convenzione equivale a pensare
agli indici del primo vettore come
aventi importanza maggiore degli indici del secondo vettore,
quindi puoi vedere che mentre
scorriamo gli elementi del prodotto tensoriale, abbiamo tutti i prodotti che coinvolgono il primo elemento del
vettore a sinistra,
che è alpha uno. Poi tutti i prodotti
che coinvolgono il secondo elemento del vettore a sinistra,
che è alpha due e così via.
Ecco un esempio in cui
il vettore a sinistra ha tre elementi e il vettore a
destra ha quattro elementi, così possiamo vedere più
chiaramente cosa sta succedendo.
WEBVTT
Abbiamo tre elementi nel primo vettore, quindi iniziamo scrivendo tre copie del secondo vettore e poi moltiplichiamo ciascuna di quelle copie
per l'elemento corrispondente
nel primo vettore in questo modo.
Portiamo gli alpha all'interno in questo modo, e qui stiamo semplicemente
moltiplicando vettori per scalari
e infine rimuoviamo le
parentesi dalle copie e formiamo un unico vettore colonna
come vedi qui.
Come nota importante, osserva che abbiamo le seguenti formule per il prodotto tensoriale di
vettori della base standard.
Se prendiamo il prodotto
tensoriale di ket a e ket b, che possiamo scrivere con
il simbolo del prodotto tensoriale o senza, come vedi qui,
allora il risultato è semplicemente ket ab.
Se vogliamo scrivere ab come coppia ordinata anziché come stringa, possiamo farlo e otteniamo
questa espressione qui,
ma è molto più comune
scrivere questa qui dove omettiamo le parentesi
ma lasciamo la virgola.
C'è un senso in cui
quella con le parentesi è forse più corretta, ma è una convenzione abbastanza standard in matematica
che le parentesi vengono rimosse quando non sono necessarie o utili.
Puoi pensarle come implicite in questa qui e semplicemente è meno disordinata
e più piacevole da guardare.
Il prodotto tensoriale ha
un'importante proprietà che è la bilinearità e ciò significa che è lineare
in ciascuno dei due argomenti a condizione che l'altro sia fisso.
Con un po' più di dettaglio, è
lineare nel primo argomento che è espresso da queste due equazioni che vedi qui,
la prima dice che
se sommiamo due vettori, Phi1 e Phi2 e poi prendiamo
il prodotto tensoriale con Psi, otteniamo lo stesso risultato se
avessimo preso il prodotto tensoriale
con Psi prima e poi avessimo sommato.
La seconda dice che se
moltiplichiamo un certo vettore Phi per un certo scalare alpha e poi prendiamo il
prodotto tensoriale con Psi,
il risultato è lo stesso come se prima avessimo preso il prodotto tensoriale di Phi e Psi e poi avessimo moltiplicato il risultato per alpha.
E abbiamo anche la linearità
nel secondo argomento che è la stessa tranne che i ruoli dei due argomenti sono scambiati.
Questa proprietà di bilinearità
è abbastanza semplice da verificare dalla definizione, ma è bene scriverla in questo modo perché spesso faremo
uso di queste formule.
Nota tra l'altro che gli scalari scorrono liberamente attraverso i prodotti tensoriali nel senso espresso da queste
uguaglianze che vedi qui.
Cioè non c'è differenza
tra moltiplicare il primo argomento per uno
scalare alpha, in questo caso moltiplicare il secondo
argomento per quello scalare
o moltiplicare l'intera
espressione per quello scalare.
Queste uguaglianze derivano da
queste due equazioni qui e poiché non c'è
differenza tra questi vettori, possiamo semplicemente scrivere
l'espressione come vedi qui
senza parentesi perché
non c'è bisogno di esse.
Non stanno aggiungendo chiarezza
né rimuovendo ambiguità, quindi le rimuoviamo e
otteniamo un'espressione più pulita.
Tutto questo si generalizza
a tre o più sistemi.
Possiamo definire il prodotto tensoriale
di tre o più vettori generalizzando la formula
per il prodotto tensoriale di due vettori in modo naturale,
come puoi vedere espresso qui. Ogni elemento del prodotto tensoriale è dato dal prodotto degli
elementi corrispondenti
dei vettori di cui
stiamo prendendo il prodotto tensoriale.
Un modo equivalente per
definire il prodotto tensoriale di tre o più vettori
è farlo ricorsivamente tornando infine alla definizione
del prodotto tensoriale tra due vettori. Quindi se n è almeno tre, possiamo pensare al
prodotto tensoriale di n vettori
Phi1 fino a Phi n come il prodotto tensoriale tra qualunque vettore otteniamo
prendendo il prodotto tensoriale dei primi n meno uno di
loro con l'ultimo vettore,
e se vuoi sapere
cos'è il prodotto tensoriale dei primi n meno uno vettori, applichi di nuovo la formula nel caso in cui n meno uno
sia almeno tre oppure usi la definizione
precedente se n meno uno è uguale a due.
I due modi di pensare
ai prodotti tensoriali di tre o più vettori sono equivalenti.
Questa volta quando abbiamo
tre o più vettori di cui stiamo prendendo il prodotto tensoriale, non usiamo il termine bilineare,
usiamo invece il termine multilineare,
ma l'idea è la stessa.
Il prodotto tensoriale è lineare
in ciascuna delle posizioni a condizione che i vettori in
tutte le altre posizioni
siano fissi. Passando alle misurazioni
di sistemi multipli in stati probabilistici,
otteniamo immediatamente una specifica per come funzionano le misurazioni
per i sistemi multipli semplicemente pensandoli
collettivamente come sistemi singoli
a condizione che tutti i
sistemi vengano misurati.
Come semplice esempio, supponiamo di avere due
bit X e Y e collettivamente si trovino in questo stato probabilistico
qui,
che abbiamo visto prima. Naturalmente, se misuriamo
entrambi questi bit, otterremo il risultato 00
ovvero uno zero per la prima misurazione e uno zero per la seconda misurazione con probabilità un mezzo e otterremo il risultato 1,1
WEBVTT
con probabilità un mezzo. È abbastanza diretto.
In sostanza, misurare tutti i sistemi equivale a misurare
l'intero sistema composto.
Se non misuriamo tutti
i sistemi, tuttavia, ma invece misuriamo solo
alcuni dei sistemi, la situazione non è
così immediatamente chiara
limitando la nostra attenzione ancora una volta al caso di soli due
sistemi per vedere l'essenza di ciò che sta accadendo nell'
impostazione più semplice possibile.
Possiamo porre la seguente domanda: supponi di avere due sistemi, X e Y che sono insieme come coppia
in un particolare stato probabilistico.
Cosa succede se misuriamo
solo X e non facciamo nulla a Y?
Beh, possiamo rispondere a questa domanda usando un po' di teoria della probabilità di base.
Prima di tutto, sappiamo che la probabilità che la misurazione
dia un particolare risultato deve essere data da questa formula
che vedi qui.
Possiamo pensare alle probabilità per ciascuno degli stati classici
della coppia XY come se avessimo misurato entrambi e sommiamo tutte le probabilità
che sono coerenti con X che si trova in qualunque stato classico
a che ci interessa.
Ecco perché la somma qui è solo sugli stati classici b di Y.
Un modo per pensare a questa
formula è che la probabilità di vedere un particolare stato classico
di X se lo misuriamo
deve essere coerente con la probabilità di vedere quello stato se
avessimo anche misurato Y, anche se non l'abbiamo fatto,
questo è molto naturale e intuitivo. La probabilità che una misurazione di X dia un particolare risultato non può dipendere dal fatto che Y
sia stato anch'esso misurato
indipendentemente dal risultato.
Quindi questo ci dice quali
sono le probabilità per i diversi possibili
risultati della misurazione, ma cosa succede a Y o alla nostra
conoscenza di Y di conseguenza?
La risposta è che potrebbe ancora
esistere una certa incertezza sullo stato di Y come
risultato dell'aver misurato X
e aver visto un particolare risultato. E quella incertezza è rappresentata da questa formula qui per la probabilità condizionale
che Y si trovi in un particolare
stato classico b, dato che X si trova in un certo stato classico,
qualunque stato classico a,
che abbia misurato.
Per essere precisi, la probabilità che Y si trovi
in un certo stato classico b, dato che X si trova nello stato classico a,
è uguale alla probabilità
che X sia in a e Y sia in b diviso per la probabilità che X
sia nello stato classico a.
Quindi se misuriamo X, vedremo
diversi stati classici con probabilità determinate
da questa formula qui
e a seconda di quale risultato otteniamo, potremmo ancora avere una certa incertezza sullo stato classico di Y e
quella incertezza si riflette
da questa formula qui.
C'è in realtà un modo molto semplice
per riformulare tutto questo e per eseguire calcoli
per casi specifici usando la notazione diretta
e funziona così.
Iniziamo scrivendo lo
stato probabilistico di XY come un vettore in questo modo, e
questo è completamente generale.
Gli elementi sono denotati da Pab e questi possono essere qualsiasi numero a condizione che l'intero vettore
sia un vettore di probabilità.
Possiamo esprimere ket ab come un
prodotto tensoriale come vedi qui e poi possiamo usare la
bilinearità del prodotto tensoriale
e specificamente il fatto che è lineare nel secondo argomento per esprimere questo vettore
come vedi qui.
Quello che stiamo facendo è effettivamente isolare i vettori della base standard
sul lato sinistro e mettere tutto quello che è necessario
sul lato destro
per permetterlo perché questo
rivelerà cosa succede quando misuriamo il primo sistema X.
Specificamente la probabilità
di ottenere un particolare risultato a è la somma di tutte le probabilità che appaiono tra
le parentesi accanto a ket a.
E condizionato sull'ottenere
un particolare risultato a, il vettore di probabilità che descrive qualsiasi incertezza residua su Y
è il vettore che era tra
le parentesi accanto ad a.
Tranne che dobbiamo normalizzarlo per renderlo un vettore di probabilità e cioè bisogna dividere quel vettore
per la somma degli elementi in quel vettore per formare un vettore di probabilità.
Qui tra l'altro, la somma è presa su tutti
c in gamma anziché b solo per usare un nome di variabile diverso in modo che non ci sia confusione
sull'ambito delle
variabili se vuoi.
Le somme al numeratore
e al denominatore devono essere considerate come cose separate e possiamo evitare qualsiasi possibilità
di confusione al riguardo
usando variabili diverse
per le due somme.
Ecco un rapido esempio per
illustrare come funziona tutto questo.
Supponiamo che XY sia una coppia di bit in questo stato probabilistico qui per capire cosa succede
quando misuriamo il primo bit
e non facciamo nulla al secondo, scriviamo il vettore come vedi qui dove ket zero e ket
uno nella prima posizione
sono isolati proprio come
abbiamo descritto poco fa.
La prima possibilità è
che il risultato della misurazione sia zero e la probabilità
che ciò accada è la somma delle probabilità
all'interno delle parentesi
WEBVTT
che sono in prodotto tensoriale con ket zero. Quindi otteniamo un dodicesimo più un quarto, che è un terzo e
condizionato sul risultato zero.
Lo stato probabilistico di Y
diventa questo vettore normalizzato o equivalentemente diviso per la probabilità
che abbiamo appena calcolato, e quindi quello che otteniamo è
questo vettore qui.
La seconda possibilità è che il risultato della misurazione sia uno e il calcolo viene
eseguito in modo simile usando il secondo termine nell'espressione
anziché il primo. E se vuoi verificare i dettagli, vai avanti come sempre e metti in pausa il video per darti un momento per farlo.
Puoi eseguire gli stessi
tipi di calcoli per capire cosa succede quando
Y viene misurato anziché X.
È lo stesso metodo per via della simmetria tra i due sistemi.
Questa volta scriviamo il
vettore di probabilità in questo modo, isolando i vettori della base standard a destra come vedi qui,
ma per il resto funziona
esattamente allo stesso modo.
Puoi anche usare questo metodo
per più di due sistemi.
Può diventare un po'
disordinato scrivere tutte le espressioni richieste, ma concettualmente è
esattamente la stessa idea.
Infine, per la parte della lezione
sull'informazione classica, daremo un'occhiata alle operazioni
sugli stati probabilistici
dei sistemi multipli. Seguendo lo stesso ragionamento che abbiamo visto un paio di volte.
Concludiamo che le operazioni probabilistiche su sistemi multipli sono proprio
come le operazioni probabilistiche su sistemi singoli rappresentate
da matrici stocastiche.
Ma questa volta quelle matrici
hanno righe e colonne che corrispondono al prodotto cartesiano degli insiemi
di stati classici dei singoli sistemi.
Cioè stiamo semplicemente
vedendo un sistema composto come se fosse un unico sistema e tornando alla descrizione di come funzionano le operazioni probabilistiche
per sistemi singoli della
lezione precedente.
Ecco un esempio di un'operazione chiamata operazione controlled-NOT
su due bit X e Y.
Questa è in realtà un'operazione deterministica e il modo in cui funziona è
che se X è uguale a uno, allora viene eseguita un'operazione NOT su Y
e altrimenti se X è uguale
a zero allora non succede nulla.
Il bit X è a volte
chiamato bit di controllo perché determina se
viene applicata o meno l'operazione NOT a Y
e Y è chiamato bit target perché è il bit su cui agisce l'operazione NOT.
Puoi anche immaginare
di scambiare i ruoli di X e Y in modo che Y diventi il bit di controllo
e X diventi il target, ma questa è un'operazione diversa
da quella descritta qui perché l'operazione non è
simmetrica tra X e Y.
Sono entrambe chiamate
operazioni controlled-NOT, e dobbiamo solo specificare
quale dei bit è il bit di controllo e
quale è il bit target.
Questa operazione ha l'azione
che vedi qui sugli stati della base standard e puoi verificare quell'azione rispetto alla definizione
dell'operazione. E qui è la rappresentazione
matriciale dell'operazione.
Quando pensiamo a questa operazione, abbiamo in mente che ci sono
questi due bit separati e svolgono i ruoli che ho appena descritto con
X come bit di controllo
e Y come bit target, ma non c'è davvero nulla
in questa azione qui o in questa rappresentazione matriciale
che richieda di
pensare a questi due bit come bit separati.
Potremmo alternativamente
pensare a questa operazione come un'operazione deterministica
su un sistema con quattro stati classici
che abbiamo deciso di chiamare
0,0, 0,1, 1,0 e 1,1.
Ecco un altro esempio di
un'operazione probabilistica su due bit, che non è un'operazione deterministica questa volta.
L'operazione imposta Y uguale a X con probabilità un mezzo e altrimenti va nell'altro verso e imposta X uguale a Y.
Questa operazione non ha un nome speciale, serve solo come esempio.
E qui è la rappresentazione
matriciale di questa operazione.
Puoi vedere che può essere espressa come media di due matrici, una che rappresenta l'operazione
deterministica
in cui Y viene impostato su qualunque
valore sia memorizzato in X e l'altra che imposta
X uguale a Y.
Quindi qui vediamo che possiamo prendere medie di matrici stocastiche per ottenerne di nuove proprio come avevamo nella lezione precedente.
Ora, consideriamo
la seguente domanda. Supponiamo di avere due
operazioni probabilistiche, ciascuna sul proprio sistema
descritte come di consueto da matrici
stocastiche e per essere precisi, supponiamo che M sia
un'operazione probabilistica
su un sistema X e N sia una
operazione probabilistica su un sistema Y.
La domanda è se
eseguiamo simultaneamente M su X e N su Y, come descriviamo
l'effetto che questo ha
sul sistema composto XY?
Pensandoci
intuitivamente per un momento, se eseguiamo simultaneamente le due operazioni sui rispettivi sistemi,
stiamo in realtà
eseguendo un'operazione sul sistema composto, quindi dovrebbe essere descritta
da qualche matrice stocastica.
La risposta breve a questa
domanda è che la matrice si ottiene prendendo un prodotto tensoriale, non tra vettori come
abbiamo discusso prima,
WEBVTT
ma tra matrici in questo
caso, le matrici M e N.
Quindi prendiamoci qualche momento
per discutere i prodotti tensoriali delle matrici e poi torneremo
a questa domanda.
Ecco la definizione
del prodotto tensoriale tra matrici ed
è molto analoga al prodotto tensoriale tra vettori.
Se supponiamo che le due
matrici con cui stiamo lavorando siano scritte nelle forme che vedi qui in modo che gli elementi di M siano
denotati alpha ab come a e b
variano su un insieme di stati classici sigma e gli elementi di N siano
denotati da beta cd come c e d
variano su un insieme di stati classici gamma.
Allora il prodotto di M e N è la matrice che vedi qui.
Quello che abbiamo è simile
al prodotto tensoriale tra vettori.
le righe e le colonne di M tensoriale N corrispondono a coppie di stati classici scritte come stringhe qui,
e gli elementi sono prodotti degli elementi corrispondenti di M e N.
Ecco un altro modo di scriverlo in termini degli elementi individuali
di queste matrici.
L'elemento ac bd di M tensoriale N è il prodotto dell'elemento ab
di M e dell'elemento cd di N.
C'è un altro modo di
descrivere M tensoriale N, che è che è la
matrice unica che trasforma qualsiasi vettore della forma Phi tensoriale Psi
nel prodotto tensoriale di M applicato a Phi con N applicato a Psi, e ciò deve essere vero per ogni scelta
di questi vettori Phi e Psi.
Un modo per pensarci
è che il prodotto tensoriale delle matrici va perfettamente d'accordo con il prodotto tensoriale tra vettori.
Questa è un'equazione che
speriamo naturalmente sia vera e in effetti lo è.
In termini di matrici scritte
esplicitamente, possiamo definire il prodotto
tensoriale come vedi qui.
Ci sono molti puntini in questa equazione e sono intesi a
illustrare lo schema, che è lo stesso schema
che avevamo per i vettori eccetto che ora abbiamo righe e colonne
al posto dei soli vettori colonna.
Nel caso non fosse chiaro, il
seguente esempio potrebbe aiutare.
Qui stiamo parlando di
il prodotto tensoriale di due matrici due per due.
Prima scriviamo quattro
copie della seconda matrice, una per ogni elemento della prima matrice.
Moltiplichiamo ciascuna di queste
copie della seconda matrice per l'elemento corrispondente
della prima matrice,
e poi raccogliamo tutto in
una singola matrice quattro per quattro come vedi qui.
Possiamo anche definire il
prodotto tensoriale di tre o più matrici in modo analogo e forse il modo più semplice per esprimerlo
è come vedi qui
dove abbiamo una formula per ogni elemento del prodotto tensoriale, che è semplicemente il prodotto
degli elementi corrispondenti.
Puoi anche definire il prodotto tensoriale di tre o più matrici ricorsivamente in termini di prodotto
tensoriale di solo due matrici proprio come avevamo per i vettori.
E una nota finale è
che il prodotto tensoriale delle matrici è moltiplicativo, il che significa che un
prodotto di prodotti tensoriali
è uguale al prodotto tensoriale
dei prodotti.
Puoi pensarci
come una generalizzazione della formula di poco fa per l'azione del prodotto
tensoriale di matrici
sul prodotto tensoriale di vettori. E ancora, questo è qualcosa che
speriamo sia vero e possiamo essere contenti che lo sia
e lo useremo
quando ne avremo bisogno.
E ora possiamo tornare alla
domanda di prima che chiede come descriviamo
l'effetto dell'esecuzione di un'operazione M su un sistema X
e un'operazione N sul sistema Y insieme come operazione
sul sistema composto XY.
E la risposta a quella
domanda è che l'azione è descritta dal
prodotto tensoriale di M e N.
I prodotti tensoriali rappresentano l'indipendenza questa volta tra operazioni in contrapposizione a ciò che abbiamo visto
prima per i vettori di probabilità.
Ecco un rapido esempio. Supponiamo di eseguire
l'operazione probabilistica descritta da questa matrice su un bit X.
Questa è un'operazione
che abbiamo visto nella lezione uno e simultaneamente eseguiamo
un'operazione NOT su un bit Y.
L'operazione combinata sulla coppia XY è quindi rappresentata dal prodotto tensoriale delle matrici corrispondenti a queste due operazioni.
Ecco quella su X e
ecco l'operazione NOT su Y e otteniamo questa matrice
che vedi qui.
E puoi vedere che in effetti
questa è una matrice stocastica e sarà sempre così.
Il prodotto tensoriale di qualsiasi
due matrici stocastiche o di qualsiasi numero di matrici stocastiche
sarà sempre stocastico.
È una situazione molto comune
che si incontra in cui un'operazione viene eseguita su un sistema e nulla viene fatto a un altro sistema.
In questa situazione, seguiamo esattamente la stessa prescrizione con la comprensione che non fare nulla è rappresentato dalla matrice identità.
Per esempio, se abbiamo due bit X e
Y e azzeriamo il bit X allo stato zero, che è la stessa cosa
che eseguire la funzione
costante zero su X e non facciamo nulla a Y, allora l'operazione risultante sulla coppia XY
WEBVTT
è rappresentata da questo
prodotto tensoriale qui.
Tutto questo si generalizza
a qualsiasi numero di sistemi e vedremo alcuni esempi aggiuntivi quando passiamo al contesto quantistico, che funziona esattamente nello stesso modo
tranne per il fatto che abbiamo matrici unitarie anziché matrici stocastiche, e questo basta sull'informazione
classica per ora.
Ora rivolgeremo la nostra attenzione
all'informazione quantistica e a come funziona per i sistemi multipli.
Lo schema è lo stesso di quanto
era per l'informazione classica.
Possiamo vedere sistemi quantistici multipli come singoli sistemi composti e applicare ciò che sappiamo
dalla lezione precedente.
Ancora una volta, i prodotti tensoriali
giocheranno un ruolo chiave e complessivamente otteniamo una descrizione di come funziona l'informazione quantistica
per i sistemi multipli.
Che è molto analoga
e matematicamente simile a ciò che abbiamo appena visto per
l'informazione classica.
Inizieremo con gli stati quantistici.
Gli stati quantistici dei sistemi multipli sono rappresentati da vettori colonna con elementi di numeri complessi
e norma euclidea pari a uno
proprio come gli stati quantistici
dei sistemi singoli.
Questa volta gli indici dei
vettori di stato quantistico corrispondono al prodotto cartesiano degli insiemi di stati classici
dei singoli sistemi
perché ancora una volta, quello è
l'insieme degli stati classici del sistema composto.
Per esempio, se X e Y sono qubit, allora l'insieme degli stati classici
della coppia XY insieme è il prodotto cartesiano dell'alfabeto
binario con se stesso,
che possiamo pensare come
l'insieme di tutte le stringhe binarie di lunghezza due.
Quindi questi vettori che vedi qui sono tutti esempi di vettori di stato quantistico di XY.
Se vogliamo, possiamo alternativamente scrivere
questi vettori in questo modo dove abbiamo un ket separato
per ogni qubit
dove il prodotto tensoriale
tra loro è implicito.
Oppure possiamo anche scrivere il
simbolo del prodotto tensoriale esplicitamente in questo modo se preferisci.
E un'altra opzione è
sottoscrivere i ket con i nomi dei sistemi
che rappresentano in questo modo.
E puoi farlo con
il simbolo del prodotto tensoriale o senza.
Questo a volte può essere molto utile per tenere le cose ordinate.
Questi sono solo stili diversi per esprimere gli stessi vettori e possiamo scegliere quello che vogliamo o quello che preferiamo o
quello che ha più senso
per la situazione in questione. Quando le cose diventano più
complicate ad esempio, potremmo decidere che uno di
questi stili aggiunge chiarezza
e siamo liberi di fare
la scelta che vogliamo.
I prodotti tensoriali di vettori di stato quantistico sono anch'essi vettori di stato quantistico.
Nel caso di due sistemi ad esempio, se Phi è un vettore di stato quantistico
di un sistema X e Psi è un vettore di stato quantistico
di un sistema Y,
allora il prodotto tensoriale di Phi e Psi è un vettore di stato quantistico di XY.
Chiamiamo stati come questi stati prodotto e simile a ciò che abbiamo visto nel contesto classico probabilistico, rappresentano l'indipendenza
tra i sistemi X e Y.
Quindi per esempio, se una persona ha un laboratorio
in una parte del mondo e crea un sistema X e lo inizializza allo stato quantistico Phi
e un'altra persona in
un'altra parte del mondo inizializza indipendentemente un sistema Y allo stato quantistico Psi,
allora se scegliamo di pensare a XY come formante un unico sistema anche se è in due parti o in diverse parti del mondo,
allora il sistema composto XY è
nello stato Phi tensoriale Psi.
Tutto questo si generalizza a
più di due sistemi in modo naturale.
Se abbiamo stati quantistici
Psi1 fino a PsiN di sistemi separati X1 fino a Xn, allora il prodotto tensoriale di questi n vettori
rappresenta uno stato quantistico, chiamato ancora stato prodotto del sistema composto X1 fino a Xn.
Ecco un esempio di uno
stato quantistico di due qubit.
Anche se potrebbe non
sembrarlo immediatamente. È un esempio di stato prodotto perché possiamo scriverlo
come prodotto tensoriale come vedi qui.
Quindi è un esempio di uno
stato prodotto indipendentemente da come è scritto, ciò che è rilevante è se
è possibile o meno scriverlo come prodotto tensoriale.
Questo stato quantistico, tuttavia, che è ancora uno stato di due
qubit, non è uno stato prodotto.
È simile nello spirito
all'esempio che abbiamo visto nel contesto probabilistico di due bit casuali perfettamente correlati
e lo stesso argomento rivela che non può essere scritto
come prodotto tensoriale.
Quindi spostiamo questo qui e diamo un'occhiata all'argomento con un po' più di dettaglio.
Immaginiamo di poter
scrivere questo stato come prodotto tensoriale di
due vettori Phi e Psi.
L'elemento corrispondente
allo stato classico 0,1 è zero per questo vettore, il che possiamo vedere solo guardandolo.
Questo implicherebbe tuttavia, se il vettore fosse un prodotto
tensoriale di due vettori, che l'elemento zero di Phi
per l'elemento uno di Psi
sarebbe uguale a zero, ma ciò significa che o
l'elemento zero di Phi o l'elemento uno di Psi è uguale a zero
o entrambi potrebbero essere uguale a zero, ma ciò contraddice il fatto
che questi due prodotti qui devono essere entrambi diversi da zero.
WEBVTT
Sono uguali a uno
su radice quadrata di due. L'argomento è in realtà abbastanza
identico a quello che avevamo nel contesto probabilistico.
Non c'è nulla di unicamente
quantistico in tutto questo.
In ogni caso, quello che troviamo è che lo stato originale non è uno stato prodotto.
Nota che non è importante
che questi due numeri qui siano uno su radice quadrata di due.
Tutto ciò che conta è che
entrambi i valori siano diversi da zero.
Questo particolare stato quantistico
è uno molto interessante. È un esempio di uno
stato entangled di due qubit.
Parleremo di più dell'
entanglement più avanti nella serie.
L'entanglement può essere complicato, in particolare quando parliamo
di stati quantistici nella formulazione generale
dell'informazione quantistica,
ma qui nella descrizione semplificata dell'informazione quantistica l'entanglement è equivalente a una mancanza di indipendenza.
Quindi per un vettore di stato quantistico,
se non è uno stato prodotto, è uno stato entangled
e questo particolare stato
è comunemente visto come
l'esempio archetipico di uno stato quantistico entangled.
E in effetti, a volte
pensiamo a questo stato come che rappresenta un'unità di entanglement, in particolare quando stiamo
pensando all'entanglement
come una risorsa che può essere
utilizzata per fare cose interessanti.
Lo stato quantistico di cui
abbiamo appena parlato è uno dei quattro cosiddetti stati di Bell, che puoi vedere qui
insieme ai nomi
comunemente usati per questi stati, Phi plus, Phi minus,
Psi plus e Psi minus.
Sono tutti entangled
e formano una base per lo spazio di tutti
i vettori che rappresentano stati di due qubit.
Quindi questi quattro vettori insieme
sono chiamati la base di Bell.
È una raccolta di stati quantistici
molto comunemente incontrata, chiamata
in onore di John Bell, che era un fisico che ha dato
contributi molto importanti
allo studio dell'entanglement negli anni '60.
Ecco un paio di esempi ben noti di stati quantistici di tre qubit.
Il primo è chiamato stato GHZ.
È un po' come lo stato Phi
plus che abbiamo appena visto tranne che per tre qubit invece di due.
E il secondo esempio è chiamato stato W e si presenta come vedi qui, quindi è uniforme sulle
tre stringhe binarie
di lunghezza tre che hanno
esattamente un bit impostato a uno.
Nessuno di questi stati è uno stato prodotto e hanno entrambi proprietà interessanti e appaiono abbastanza comunemente come esempi, quindi vale la pena conoscerli
e li vedremo ancora.
Prossimamente parleremo delle
misurazioni dei sistemi in stati quantistici.
Seguendo lo stesso ragionamento
che abbiamo seguito finora in questa lezione, ovvero pensare a sistemi multipli
come se fossero sistemi singoli. Arriviamo immediatamente a una descrizione di come funzionano le misurazioni di
sistemi quantistici multipli
a condizione che tutti i
sistemi vengano misurati.
Cioè se abbiamo qualche
vettore di stato quantistico Psi che rappresenta uno stato quantistico
di una n-upla di sistemi
X1 fino a Xn e misuriamo
l'intero sistema composto, che equivale a misurare
ognuno dei singoli sistemi, allora ogni possibile n-upla
di stati classici sarà il risultato della misurazione
con probabilità pari al
valore assoluto al quadrato dell'elemento di Psi che
corrisponde a quella n-upla.
Per esempio, se abbiamo
una coppia di sistemi XY in questo stato quantistico qui, allora se misuriamo entrambi i sistemi,
otterremo il risultato zero cuori ovvero zero per la misurazione di X e cuori per la misurazione di Y
con probabilità nove venticinquesimi e otterremo il risultato uno
picche con probabilità 16/25.
È davvero abbastanza diretto. Stiamo essenzialmente ignorando il fatto che questi sono due sistemi separati e li stiamo vedendo come se
fossero un unico sistema,
ma questo solleva la
seguente domanda naturale, che abbiamo già considerato
nel contesto classico.
Supponiamo di avere due sistemi X e Y che si trovano collettivamente
in un certo stato quantistico e non misuriamo entrambi, ma
misuriamo solo un sistema.
Diciamo che misuriamo il sistema X e non facciamo nulla a Y.
Naturalmente, possiamo anche chiederci cosa succede se misuriamo Y e non
X e più in generale cosa succede se abbiamo
tre o più sistemi
e ne misuriamo un sottoinsieme proprio. Ma una volta che abbiamo una
risposta a questa domanda, avremo le risposte anche a
quelle domande.
Sappiamo che in generale
un vettore di stato quantistico della coppia XY assume la
forma che vedi qui, assumendo come al solito che sigma e gamma
siano gli insiemi di stati classici
di X e Y rispettivamente.
Gli elementi di questo vettore sono
denotati da alpha ab che variano su tutte le possibili scelte di a e b,
e possono essere qualsiasi numero complesso tale da rendere questo vettore
un vettore unitario.
Ora sappiamo già che se
entrambi i sistemi vengono misurati, allora otteniamo le probabilità per i diversi possibili risultati
WEBVTT
prendendo il valore assoluto al quadrato dell'elemento corrispondente.
E quindi se viene misurato solo X, allora la probabilità di
ottenere un particolare risultato a è data da questa espressione,
sommiamo semplicemente su tutti i
possibili risultati b, che potrebbero essere ottenuti
se Y fosse stato misurato anche se non lo era.
L'idea è la stessa del
contesto probabilistico.
La probabilità di ottenere
un particolare risultato quando X viene misurato non può
dipendere da se Y sia stato misurato o meno.
Quindi questo ci dice quali
sono le probabilità per i diversi possibili risultati.
Inoltre, ci sarà un certo
cambiamento nello stato di Y come risultato dell'aver
eseguito questa misurazione su X e aver ottenuto un particolare risultato.
Quindi vediamo come funziona questo.
Simile a quanto abbiamo fatto nel
contesto probabilistico, possiamo esprimere il
vettore di stato quantistico Psi come vedi qui
dove Phi a è questo vettore per ogni scelta di uno stato classico a del sistema X,
stiamo usando la bilinearità
del prodotto tensoriale proprio come prima.
Solo che ora abbiamo scelto di dare un nome
a questi diversi vettori Phi a, solo per comodità.
Abbiamo già osservato che la probabilità che la misurazione produca
ogni possibile risultato a è come vedi qui,
ma ora possiamo vedere che questa probabilità è uguale alla norma euclidea
al quadrato del vettore Phi a,
e ora come risultato della misurazione di X che dà un particolare risultato a, abbiamo che lo stato quantistico
del sistema composto XY
diventa questo stato che
vedi qui.
Proprio come avevamo per i sistemi singoli, lo stato collassa in sostanza, ma non collassa
completamente in generale,
collassa solo quanto è necessario per essere coerente
con la misurazione di X che produce il risultato a.
Lo stato quantistico di Y diventa Phi a normalizzato, ovvero dividiamo per la sua norma euclidea
in modo che diventi un vettore unitario. Questo è analogo a ciò che è accaduto nel
contesto probabilistico dove invece di dividere
per la norma euclidea,
dividevamo per la somma
degli elementi di Phi a per ottenere un vettore di probabilità.
Ma qui perché stiamo
parlando di stati quantistici, dividiamo per la norma euclidea
per ottenere un vettore di stato quantistico.
Diamo un'occhiata a un paio di esempi per vedere come funziona
per uno stato specifico.
Ecco lo stato che considereremo. Supponiamo che X e Y siano qubit e si trovino in questo particolare stato Psi.
E supponiamo che X venga misurato.
Iniziamo scrivendo lo stato
Psi come vedi qui, isolando efficacemente i
fattori della base standard di X
e mettendoli in prodotto tensoriale con quello che ci serve per ottenere lo stato originale.
Proprio come nella descrizione generale
di poco fa.
La probabilità di ottenere il risultato zero è la norma euclidea al quadrato
di questo vettore qui.
La cosa che è in prodotto tensoriale con ket zero nella nostra espressione del vettore Psi.
E quindi la probabilità è tre quarti e condizionato sull'
ottenere il risultato zero.
Lo stato quantistico della
coppia XY diventa questo dove normalizziamo il
vettore in prodotto tensoriale con ket zero,
e ciò equivale a
dividere per la radice quadrata della probabilità che
abbiamo appena calcolato.
Possiamo poi semplificare
e questo è quello che otteniamo.
La probabilità di ottenere il
risultato della misurazione uno viene calcolata in modo simile.
Prendiamo la norma euclidea al quadrato
di questo vettore qui. La cosa che è in prodotto tensoriale con ket
uno nella nostra espressione di Psi
e la probabilità risultante
è un quarto, il che deve essere ovviamente, perché le nostre probabilità
devono sommarsi a uno.
In questo caso, lo stato quantistico di XY diventa questo dove di nuovo normalizziamo dividendo per la norma euclidea
in modo da ottenere questo vettore di stato
quantistico come risultato.
Lo stesso metodo viene usato
in modo simmetrico, se Y viene misurato invece di X.
Ecco il vettore di stato quantistico originale, e questa volta poiché Y
viene misurato invece di X,
esprimiamo il vettore Psi
come vedi qui, dove questa volta isoliamo i
vettori della base standard di Y
anziché X mettendoli in prodotto tensoriale
con quello che ci serve per ottenere un'espressione di Psi.
Svolgendo il calcolo, che puoi verificare
mettendo in pausa il video se vuoi.
Vediamo che la probabilità
di ottenere il risultato zero è 5/8 questa volta, e qui è il vettore di stato quantistico
che risulta condizionato
all'ottenere quel risultato.
E la probabilità di ottenere il
risultato uno è tre ottavi, nel qual caso questo è
il nostro vettore di stato quantistico.
Puoi usare esattamente lo stesso metodo nel caso in cui hai più di due sistemi e un sottoinsieme proprio
di essi viene misurato.
WEBVTT
E c'è un esempio
nel contenuto del libro di testo per questa lezione che puoi
consultare se sei interessato.
In breve, possiamo sempre dividere i sistemi in due raccolte separate, quelli che vengono misurati
e quelli che non lo sono.
E una volta che lo abbiamo fatto, ricadiamo sul metodo
metodo che ho appena descritto, ed è così che funzionano le misurazioni per sistemi quantistici multipli.
E infine, passiamo alle operazioni unitarie
su sistemi multipli.
Usando la stessa idea di base che i sistemi multipli possono essere visti come sistemi composti singoli.
Concludiamo ciò che vedi
scritto qui sullo schermo, le operazioni quantistiche sui sistemi composti sono rappresentate da matrici unitarie
proprio come abbiamo per i sistemi singoli e in particolare le righe e le colonne di quelle matrici unitarie corrispondono al prodotto cartesiano
degli insiemi di stati classici di qualunque raccolta di
sistemi di cui stiamo parlando.
Per esempio, se abbiamo un sistema X
i cui stati classici sono uno, due e tre e Y è un qubit,
allora la matrice che vedi qui è un esempio di matrice unitaria che rappresenta un'
operazione sulla coppia XY.
I dettagli di come
ordiniamo i prodotti cartesiani di cui abbiamo parlato prima non contano davvero per
il bene di questo esempio, è solo una matrice sei per sei
che risulta essere unitaria.
Non c'è nulla di speciale in essa, sebbene sia costruita da un
paio di matrici importanti.
Il punto è che potresti
scegliere qualsiasi matrice unitaria sei per sei e rappresenterebbe
un'operazione unitaria su XY.
Se applichiamo una raccolta di
operazioni unitarie in modo indipendente ognuna sul proprio sistema, allora l'azione di tutte insieme
sul sistema composto è
data dal prodotto tensoriale.
E qui sullo schermo puoi vedere un'affermazione più precisa
di quel fatto.
Se le nostre operazioni unitarie sono descritte dalle matrici unitarie U1 fino a Un, una per ciascuno dei nostri sistemi,
allora l'azione combinata
sul sistema composto è data dal prodotto
tensoriale di U1 fino a Un.
Ancora una volta, simile a quanto avevamo nel contesto probabilistico, un esempio importante è che
applichiamo una certa operazione unitaria
U a un sistema X e non
facciamo nulla a un altro sistema Y.
L'operazione su XY che otteniamo è U in prodotto tensoriale con la matrice identità.
La matrice identità
descrive il non fare nulla a Y.
A volte è utile scrivere esplicitamente che questa matrice identità
corrisponde al sistema Y, solo per rendere le formule più chiare.
E un'opzione è
dare alla matrice identità un pedice come questo che indica il sistema su cui agisce.
Quando è sufficientemente chiaro, però, di solito non
ci preoccupiamo del pedice, ma quando le cose diventano più complicate, può essere molto utile.
E possiamo anche considerare
il caso simmetrico in cui una certa operazione unitaria
V viene applicata a Y e non viene fatto nulla a X,
e questa volta l'operazione unitaria risultante su XY è rappresentata da questo
prodotto tensoriale qui.
E ancora una volta, possiamo mettere un pedice sulla
matrice identità se aiuta.
Ecco un paio di esempi specifici.
Se X e Y sono qubit e
eseguiamo un'operazione Hadamard su X e non facciamo nulla a Y, otteniamo la matrice che vedi qui.
Se d'altra parte, eseguiamo l'operazione Hadamard su Y e non facciamo nulla a X, l'ordine del prodotto tensoriale si inverte.
E quindi otteniamo la matrice
che vedi qui.
Non ogni operazione unitaria
su un sistema composto può essere espressa come prodotto tensoriale.
Se abbiamo un prodotto tensoriale,
allora abbiamo indipendenza.
E ci sono alcuni esempi abbastanza
fondamentali di operazioni che certamente
non agiscono in modo indipendente su sistemi multipli.
Per esempio, se X e Y hanno
lo stesso insieme di stati classici, che potrebbe essere qualsiasi
insieme di stati classici sigma,
possiamo pensare all'operazione
di swap sulla coppia XY.
Questa operazione non cambia l'ordinamento dei due sistemi, abbiamo ancora X a
sinistra e Y a destra, ma rappresenta
lo scambio del contenuto
dei due sistemi. Qui puoi vedere che è espresso
nella forma di un'equazione dove abbiamo un
prodotto tensoriale di due stati quantistici.
Un altro modo per scriverlo è come
una matrice come vediamo qui.
Il modo in cui puoi pensare
a questa descrizione è che ti dice cosa succede per i vettori della base standard.
E una volta che sappiamo cosa succede
per i vettori della base standard, sappiamo cosa succede per
stati quantistici arbitrari per linearità,
che in effetti è vero anche per
questa espressione qui.
Quindi questa particolare operazione qui risulta essere un'operazione deterministica oltre che un'operazione unitaria.
Se X e Y sono qubit, per esempio, otteniamo questa rappresentazione
matriciale qui.
Ecco un interessante collegamento
tra l'operazione di swap e i quattro stati di Bell, mostrati qui
per comodità.
L'operazione di swap lascia
i primi tre invariati, ma mette un segno meno davanti allo stato Psi minus,
WEBVTT
quindi c'è qualcosa di
speciale in quello.
Puoi verificare queste equazioni direttamente guardando questi vettori e considerando cosa succede
per gli stati della base standard
scambiare i due stati classici per i primi tre stati di Bell
non fa nulla otteniamo lo stesso stato da cui siamo partiti.
Nel quarto caso tuttavia, il segno meno si sposta effettivamente
da un termine all'altro quando eseguiamo lo swap degli stati classici,
e ciò equivale a moltiplicare il vettore per meno uno.
Quindi eseguire l'operazione di swap in qualche modo fa emergere un segno meno
da questo quarto stato di Bell.
Avremo altro da dire su
queste equazioni più avanti, ma ora passiamo a
un altro tipo di operazione, che è un'operazione controllata.
Supporremo che X sia un qubit e Y sia qualsiasi sistema tu voglia.
Se U è un'operazione unitaria su Y, allora un'operazione controlled U su XY è l'operazione
espressa qui.
Prima usando la notazione diretta e poi usando quella che viene
chiamata una matrice a blocchi immaginando di riempire questa matrice più grande
con quelle più piccole dove questi zeri rappresentano davvero matrici
riempite di zeri.
Quindi ciascuno di questi quattro blocchi rappresenta una matrice con un numero
di righe e colonne che corrisponde al numero
di stati classici di Y.
L'idea di un'operazione controllata, che abbiamo già incontrato
nel contesto classico quando abbiamo discusso un'operazione
controlled NOT,
è che se X è impostato a zero,
allora non succede nulla a Y.
Ma se X è impostato a uno,
allora U viene applicato a Y.
Quindi X è chiamato il qubit di controllo, e Y è chiamato il sistema target, che in generale non
deve essere un qubit.
Per un esempio specifico,
che ho appena menzionato, abbiamo un'operazione controlled NOT.
Se il primo qubit è impostato
a zero, non succede nulla. E se il primo qubit è impostato a uno, allora viene eseguita un'operazione NOT, o equivalentemente,
un'operazione sigma X viene
applicata al secondo qubit.
E qui è la sua rappresentazione matriciale.
Stiamo parlando di due qubit qui, quindi potremmo ugualmente decidere che il secondo qubit è il controllo e il
primo è il target.
Per descrivere quell'operazione, invertiamo semplicemente l'ordine
nel prodotto tensoriale, e il risultato è la matrice
che vedi qui.
Se invece di un'operazione controlled-NOT, consideriamo un'operazione controlled sigma
Z o controlled Z.
Otteniamo questa rappresentazione
matriciale qui. E per questa, non conta effettivamente
quale è il controllo e quale è il target.
Otteniamo lo stesso risultato in entrambi i casi.
Possiamo andare oltre e considerare un'operazione controlled swap.
E qui stiamo
parlando di scambiare due qubit, quindi finiamo con tre qubit quando includiamo il qubit di controllo.
La rappresentazione matriciale di ciascuno
è come questa.
È un'operazione piuttosto speciale ed è nota come operazione Fredkin, o più comunemente gate Fredkin.
Quando pensiamo a essa
come a un gate in un circuit, discuteremo i circuit nella prossima lezione.
L'ultimo esempio è un'operazione controlled,
controlled-NOT, che è ancora un'operazione su tre qubit.
Ed ecco la sua rappresentazione matriciale. Questa operazione è molto meglio
nota come operazione Toffoli o gate Toffoli.
Ne parleremo ulteriormente
e vedremo perché sia essa che l'operazione Fredkin sono operazioni molto importanti
in una lezione successiva.
E questa è la fine della seconda lezione. In questa lezione, abbiamo discusso come funziona l'informazione quantistica per i sistemi multipli.
Spero che ti unirai a me per
la terza lezione presto, che parla di circuit quantistici,
protocolli e giochi.
Arrivederci a presto.